Dark Souls 3 is right around the corner
and Mike we just got to see a preview of
it yeah we played about three hours I
think they gave us four but we played
about a little less than that and we got
to see all three bosses and kill Halden
that's right and there was also a new
area we've never been to before yeah so
we went through the area which was in
the beta and the stress test they
released which is a la vics wall or
Lawford high wall something similar and
then we went to the undead settlement
right after that which actually was very
blood-borne esque that's right so
basically with our time with it we found
5 pretty important things that we
learned with our time with it we're
going to go over those right now first
one is they've made a real nice hub area
where everything is nice and contained
now in Dark Souls 2 they kind of did
that but it was a was like an entire
area it was like a world where as this
one's all contained within a little
mansion house yes they're calling it
Firelink shrine and it's essentially you
know they have the home bonfire that you
can warp 2 and then you have the fire
keeper which is the person who levels
you up using souls you have Andre the
blacksmith so people that play dark
souls 1 a lot will recognize the name in
his face and there's the handmade
merchant which is essentially the item
seller and you can get usable items you
can get just clothes from her but by and
large you're going to be going to Andre
for armor and weapon upgrades so yeah
you'll be returning here a lot just to
whether you're leveling up or just
infusing weapons which get into later or
just kind of need to go back and
rekindle as it turns out you can do ice
the second one is hollowing is out and
embers are in it looks like in this
version similar to a way you would
consider hollowing which is you know
when you die and you lose your humanity
and eventually have to get that back so
you can regain
max health now it's called embers and it
works a little differently yeah so when
you die which we did a lot during our
time the game as most people do you stop
being what they're calling the kindled
one this whole game the story revolves
around you know these people coming back
to reclaim the ember or something
similar but um when you awake at the
bonfire you have a little less max hit
points but also you don't have your emer
anymore so there is there are items that
you find that it's called embers and you
can either kill a boss to have your
ember restored as it says or use the
ember which will fill your help up all
the way but you can only use one her
life so they're probably you know
they're going to be more important as
you play through the game it also looked
like something you could use as a last
resort so if you run out of all your SS
flasks and you're almost done with the
boss you can use an ember to kind of
fill up your health just to get those
last few hits and kind of finish it up
another new thing that we found is more
combat variety looks like real
comparable to previous games in the dark
souls series it's giving you more
opportunities outside of your standard
sword and shield yeah so those were
largely focused around those kind of
slow methodical fights Dark Souls 1 and
2 but now even more so than in Dark
Souls 2 which kind of open it up you can
really just tailor to your place though
you know we were in the beta when you
and I played a few months ago we were
kind of both trying out the dual
wielding we also you know tried the
typical sword and shield with the night
I was the warrior which is kind of a new
barbarian in the demo we played and the
big axe yeah and I was pretty much just
do a willing to act the whole time just
relying on my dodge and upping my
endurance whenever I could when I was
leveling up so it definitely seems like
they are kind of using blood-borne as
you know the jumping off point to
introduce a little bit of a little bit
more speed to Dark Souls which I'm all
on board for I really like blood borns
combat so you know going back to that
mix of blood-borne and dark souls 2 it
looks really appealing another major
point that we should definitely talk
about are the weapon arts and how
they've majorly influenced an
layer to the combat mechanics in Dark
Souls yes this is another area where
blood-borne is kind of influencing Dark
Souls moving forward and I know that you
know same thing can be said vice versa
but here the weapon arts kind of
function like trick weapons didn't
blood-borne where they have an alternate
attack essentially you switch to two
handed stance and then Michael the left
trigger and then if you know some of
them are buffs like if you have a battle
axe it's just this damage buff the
longsword to actually have these
alternate like sweeping attacks and
they're really kind of adding another
thing to consider to the combat because
they're also limited you have FP points
which it becomes this resource that
you're managing much like health you
know when to use your Estus flask for
health now it's when you use the flasks
to you know save the FP points maybe fur
like the boss battle ideally but every
once in a while you're gonna run into a
huge group of people so that damage buff
with the battle axe might come in handy
for just getting you to the boss there's
a big risk reward factor to it it's kind
of making the combat a lot more dynamic
than it was enough Dark Soul 1 and 2 and
demon souls yeah adds a little bit of
strategy to decide when you're gonna
actually use that and and how much to
use I know as a sorcerer my double
handed weapon was a damage boost in a
defense boost that's really really
important and those change based on what
weapon you're holding right yeah so you
know the spears will have different ones
the certain wands will have different
ones the Sorcerer's staff will have
different ones water unconfirmed but
from what we played during the demo you
know the battle axe I guess I'd had the
damage buff long swords have those kind
of alternate more stylish attacks you're
playing the sorcerer just gives you a
nice little boost for like very short
amount time like seven seconds and then
finally last thing we really noticed was
you can reinforce your weapon but you
can infuse them now which can change the
type of damage that you want to add on
to so you're reinforcing is like your
base stats but you're the infuse
something new where you can actually add
elemental damage yeah so you'll start
picking up raw gems or like titanite
shards in the world I found a few of
each and one of the raw gems just allow
me to do the refined battle ax' which
was kind of like reinforcing it but it
just up the damage self but i also found
you can find fire gems so your weapon
will have permanent fire damage as
opposed to just using fire paper or
you know the resin in Dark Souls or
blood-borne to give a temporary buff so
that could really you know even more so
like with the character class and this
combined you could really make like a
specific character with like a fire axe
and like that's going to do a lot of
damage to enemies with those weaknesses
so I'm looking forward to seeing how
many different ones there will be
because we only saw I only saw three
there was like the refine battle axe
there was the fire axe and then the
other one was pretty you know just
regular reinforcement sweet so those are
the top five things that we learned that
we think you guys should know about if
you guys saw anything else you're
interested let us know in the comments
what you are most excited about for dark
souls 3 and you guys can expect to see
that coming out april eleventh on pc ps4
and xbox one thanks a lot thanks man
[Music]